what's going on guys welcome back to
geek culture explained my name is rob
and in this video i'm gonna reveal to
you guys how it is that i know
the eternals are going to introduce
mutants into the marvel cinematic
universe and how the marvel cinematic
universe is going to use the
introduction of mutants in the eternals
to introduce the x-men later on and in
this whole process
i'm gonna blow your mind so how are the
eternals gonna introduce mutants into
the marvel cinematic universe well we've
done this before so i'll give you guys a
quick and dirty explanation here when
the celestials show up on earth in the
early days yes they create the eternals
which is basically what humans are
capable of if their genes are pushed to
the absolute extreme
the peak of human potential which is the
ability to tap into cosmic energy they
also create the deviants when they
destabilize their genes and create
unchecked mutations with no one's guess
on what kind of mutations they're going
to get the third group had their genes
modified so that at a future point in
time
powers would develop that's where
mutants come from the role of the
eternals is to protect humans from the
deviants
now with that out of the way let's blow
your mind with some really cool stuff
so do you guys remember in captain
america the first avenger when we had an
organization called the ssr the
strategic scientific reserve which was
founded by howard stark peggy carter and
chester phillips played by tommy lee
jones and remember how towards the end
of that movie that we had arnem zola who
was rolled into the ssr to basically
work as their scientific guy who could
help them find a way to control
the tesseract so they could defeat hydra
and remember in captain america the
winter soldier when aramzola revealed
that hydra had been secretly
growing inside of shield and arnamzolla
was the biggest reason why that happened
in the first place all that's super
important
why because of marvel comics there's an
organization called weapons plus
weapons plus was a joint venture between
canada's department h and the united
states cia and the whole idea behind
this was to basically create more
captain america because steve rogers was
believed to have been dead when he was
actually frozen in a block of ice and so
the results of this is that you had all
kinds of different experiments here
technically it was called weapon one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
kind of a fun fact here captain america
was weapon one also known as project
rebirth weapons two through nine gave us
a whole bunch of different things one of
these guys was a person by the name of
frank simpson does that not sound
familiar to you frank simpson appeared
in jessica jones he was the guy who
would pop those pills to amp himself up
and bring himself back down again
kind of a cool character no idea if he's
going to stay in continuity anymore but
then we get to weapon 10. the importance
behind weapon 10 is that in the 1960s in
marvel comics you had a group called
team x
and team x worked for the cia through
weapons plus and the whole purpose
behind this is that team x would
basically topple government
take out anybody who was a political
opponent to american capitalism they
were basically an assassination or a
black ops wet work team now a few of
these members you've heard
of some of you may have it the two that
you have heard of are sabretooth and
wolverine
the other two that you've never heard of
are mastodon and silver fox and i guess
you could consider maverick if you want
to doesn't really matter
those last three don't really have an
important place in this wolverine is
really the most important here because
ultimately word reached the ears of
weapons plus that wolverine had a
healing factor
and so what weapons plus did is they
brought him in as the 10th iteration of
the weapons plus program also known
as weapon x now the importance behind
this is that this is how wolverine
became
wolverine now let's move away from the
main marvel universe here for a second
and let's go to a line of comics issued
by marvel in the year 2000 called
the ultimate comics now the reason why
this matters is because the ultimate
universe
is basically what the marvel cinematic
universe is based off of that in a
universe called earth 98
which is where superheroes age in real
time but the important thing here is
that the ultimate universe
is the most significant thing when it
comes to putting mutants into the mcu
why is that the case because in the
ultimate universe the origin of mutants
was such
that basically james hallett was taken
by canada to create
a new iteration of a super soldier
during the attempt to turn james howlett
into a super soldier
they discovered a hidden gene and when
it was activated he ended up developing
a healing factor
following that the ability to activate
those genes was synthesized
spread across the world and then what do
you know you have mutants now
let's tie all this together and create a
cohesive timeline
on how mutants are going to appear in
eternals running all the way up to the
appearance of the x-men
and the marvel cinematic universe in the
modern day so start with the eternals
celestials show up on
earth celestials modify the genes of
early man some of those individuals
genes manifest at a future point in time
they're mutants they just stay there for
a long time nobody ever really develops
any powers nobody ever really becomes
special they're just people going around
and living their lives
fast forward to the death of captain
america or the perceived death of
captain america
at the end of captain america the first
avenger that when arnam zola's brought
in arnhem zola starts regrowing hydra
hydra wants to create new captain
americas but unlike steve rogers they
want to create individuals who are loyal
to hydra
so that hydra can basically solidify
itself as a global threat possibly even
conquer the world proper
in order to do that they have to do it
secretly one because the general public
won't be too keen on a government
sanctioned intelligence organization
creating super soldiers and two no one's
supposed to know that hydra exists so
they create weapons plus
and secret and they basically start
going through and taking people
kidnapping them or even using animals
like they did in the comics
and trying to create super soldiers
following this we go into the 1960s in
the marvel cinematic universe during the
height of the cold war and we basically
have james howland
and possibly even sabertooth if you want
to who are working for team x which is
secretly an agent of hydra
and they're carrying out missions on
hydra's behalf all the while having no
idea that's the case they're military
guys they take their orders they
implement their orders they don't ask
questions now ultimately hydra realizes
how effective team x is and they say hey
maybe these guys would make great super
soldiers maybe we can find a way to
duplicate the super soldier's theorem
from steve rogers
we'll put it in them and then we'll have
like a black ops team that can do stuff
that captain america could do
and imagine how effective they would be
now along the way hydra realizes that
he's got a secret gene the gene that was
put in his body by the celestials during
the eternals
and so they say okay cool we're
basically going to activate this gene
just to see what happens
and they realize he has a healing factor
the other part of this is they take the
ability to activate those genes
and they hand it over to their
scientists on the off chance that maybe
there's more than one person out there
that has this kind of gene
and even if james is unique and nobody
out there has secret genes perhaps they
can find a way to modify the activation
process
to give people powers and so following
that the big question is what do we do
with this guy
enter myron maclean in marvel comics
meyer mclean was a metallurgist that
worked for the us government the reason
why he's important is because in marvel
comics because captain america had
helped the wakandans during world war ii
they gave him a little shard of
vibranium he went back to the us
government and said
make a shield out of this the government
said okay cool they handed the shard of
vibranium over to meyer maclaine and
they said make a shield out of this and
maya mclean said cool the problem is he
fell asleep halfway through the
experiment when he woke up he had the
shield which was composed of an
indestructible metal come to find out it
was basically vibranium and iron but
ultimately he tried to find a way to
duplicate the shield while he wasn't
able to create the exact material that
captain america's shield is made out of
he did discover a different metal
instead
adamantium and so maybe you have some
situation where maya mcclain is a
metallurgist working for hydra trying to
find a way to create a more durable
metal than vibranium
possibly even trying to find a way to
create more vibranium whatever the case
is
he ends up creating adamantium instead
hydra realizes how durable this
adamantium is
they bonded to wolverine's skeleton boom
now you have wolverine now as far as
activating the rest of the mutant
population across the world
you just tie that into the events of
infinity war and avengers end game and
all you say is it's just a genetic
response right that when there was a
huge amount of people who just vanished
maybe those individuals who disappeared
when they snapped back
some of those individuals genes popped
into motion they weren't supposed to
they weren't supposed to activate but
the process of being dusted and then
being recreated
just kind of jarred their genealogical
structure the result is that their x
gene activated prematurely and then what
do you know
we've got mutants in existence but again
all this is just my thoughts on this
just a theory that i'm putting out there
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section and i will catch
you all later
peace